hi i'm matt goldberg senior editor for
collider and I'm in Elton John's
hometown of Pinner and today we'll be
talking to some of the creative forces
behind Rocket Man which is now on
digital and will be on 4k blu-ray and
DVD on August 27 you know I think
probably before somebody knows a risk to
be like oh it's fantasy oh it's all
rated but do you feel like vindicated
now that the film has been so well
received it's just the nature of this
project the nature of this film and this
story and this this person that we're
kind of looking at we are telling the
story of someone who is was larger than
life even in their own life and that we
are doing a poetic retelling of that and
we're doing a imaginative retelling of
it so we I didn't want to just recreate
verbatim what happened or the clothes
that were there we always I always push
to go let's take it up several notches
let's make it a movie let's make it a
musical let's make it a spectacle
was there one in particular that you
were really looking forward to to
designing to getting to really to
recreate I mean I think that the thing
about Rocketman is that having sat down
and chatted to Dexter the whole the
whole thing of the film was we were
going to not replicate mm-hmm
we wanted to make our own film we wanted
it to be unique
a real spectacular film of Julian's
great challenge he said to me if I can
design a costume the Alton looks at and
says I wish I had worn that then we've
succeeded and that's what happened there
was a couple of others that were on our
marches to to Welton but everything else
is pretty much designed for the film
itself
[Music]
when you're working with Elton John's
music is there are any particular
challenges or any sort of signature that
he has so for me I came up with blues
and boogie-woogie and rhythm of Blues
and so so for me I hear so much of that
in his playing so many crushed notes
that kind of on the country side you've
got like kind of floyd cramer cream of
piano licks on the blue side who you eat
stuff so so for me it was about drawing
those out and giving tearin this sense
of a listening list essentially that i
would a scalpel to help us provide when
the songs start we want to be taken
somewhere else and that's been a dexter
about this index how his influences
crazy evidence of musicals he's seen
them and I went to go more Sam we talked
about it and then you know I try and
bring what I think is the right thing to
do by closing my eyes and hearing the
music while looking you know reading the
script and then thinking about how it's
gonna work and it's just great to be
able to be given such a wide paint brush
to paint the picture with musically and
I think that's what's special about the
musical that's when you can put it on
and have that man watch Saturday nights
all right for a fight again what your
soul again that monk way he creates that
amazing song that moves millions of
people around the world in the same way
doesn't matter what language they speak
what background they come from or men
women tall short thin fat whatever you
know it music has this great ability to
cross all of those barriers
it's all that kind of us those licks in
that sense
the Regency cafe stands in for the
Lancaster grill it's very difficult to
find cafes that kind of look like a cafe
would have done in the late 60s in
Rocketman
it's where elton and bernie meet for the
first time so obviously absolutely
crucial Pinner is where Elton John was
born that's where he grew up and at age
15 he started playing piano at a local
pub and we were able to shoot in the
area for the big opening sequence were
where they do the [ __ ] back that
whole big dance number shot there in the
film the Royal Albert Hall is where we
shot a couple of scenes here actually
and obviously it's a it's a place Elton
has performed in a lot over the years so
it's quite nice to do to include it in
the film
[Music]
you